here we go
all right everybody let me know with a
thumbs up if you can see me out there
along with
one of the most famous bks in the
universe uh and that is uh not me Brian
Keating but that's the Bernardo castroop
who is joining us all the way from the
Netherlands who makes him I think I
think the Netherlands are my second most
popular country Bernardo
in terms of guests yeah I just had on
aquito invents and I had on uh more
recently highgown falca many many other
Dutch men I haven't had any Dutch women
on but hopefully I'll get some Dutch
women too but you know I have a
particular fascination with the Dutch
because they invented this device here
which we're going to talk about yes
which is in the microscope as well and
the microscope and I think the uh the
first name of the person who invented
both of them are part of the name had
Hans in it Hans Lin hook and uh and then
Hans uh lippershey although I think Lee
and hook had a different other major
name anyway I I I don't know I I should
be
um
or given names in the Netherlands Is
that real oh I didn't know that wow
enhance is Johannes yes oh that's right
yes it's just nobody says Johannes
nobody and then one person and then
their uh Germany is Han Hansa right or
Hans uh the lufthansa's German airlines
right so well it's a great pleasure to
be here first I have to acknowledge uh
our our uh interlocutor who set all this
up and that is none other than uh Kirch
and mungle
of the theories of everything podcast I
should have pinged him that you'd be on
maybe I'll I'll direct message him once
we get once we get going here but it's a
great it's a great treat to have you on
the podcast and this uh sorry it's taken
so long and we we've gone back and forth
we had covet Etc but I'm uh I'm so glad
you're here Bernardo thank you so much
pleasure to be here thanks for having me
Brian uh and so I want to start just
very quickly for those very few people
that may not know who you are uh you are
a PhD uh and you know PhD in computer
engineering but you've also done
um uh significant PhD work in philosophy
in particular ontology which we'll talk
about uh you've worked in particle
physics institutions like CERN and
Phillips Research Laboratories uh and uh
and he's worked on many many
popularizations for the general audience
you've done a lot of videos including
with with
um past guests Sabina hasenfelder maybe
we'll get into that uh and uh and then
hosted by my friend Kurt so it's really
quite a a great uh honor to to meet you
and and be together finally on the phone
I know it's late there but we'll we have
a lot to cover so the first thing I want
to cover actually does relate uh not to
uh not to the telescopes inventor but
the telescopes primary user at least
initially and that's this guy here
Galileo Galilei
um who said something I want to I want
you to react to he said the job of a
scientist is to measure what's
measurable and make measurable what is
not so I.E to build instruments to build
uh tools sometimes to build mental
models uh I want to ask you to what
extent is it really even possible or
useful to build all these tools are
there certain tools that are more useful
than others and uh your your take on
what Galileo said is that the primary
aim of science to measure what's
measurable
I would say the primary aim of science
is to predict what's going to happen
next and measurement is a way to refine
our models so we can predict more
accurately
um maybe I have too much a pragmatic
view of science uh but yeah this thing
was inculcated in me since I was very
very young you know I I landed at cernet
22 that was my first job
so the notion of measurement is directly
coupled to the ability for one to
develop a predictive model and tell
what's going to happen next before it
happens
um yeah so for me that's that's the core
of science so I wanted to to uh to ask
you uh about the the kind of maybe
conflicts or maybe you could you could
comment on the work of uh in particular
Donald Hoffman when I when I think about
you I think about uh different analogies
for for Consciousness and I've come to
the feeling that it's almost hopeless
that I've had on David Chalmers and the
coiner of the hard problem of
Consciousness I want to ask you
um where does a professional kind of
feel that this notion of either you know
Consciousness as a possibility within
the scientific Enterprise first of all
is consciousness is there a role for
Science and Consciousness uh let me ask
you that to begin with
that there clearly is a role for a
science of the contents of Consciousness
and I think because they are our primary
interface the reality what you are never
conscious of directly or indirectly
might as well not exist now a science of
Consciousness in the sense of trying to
reduce Consciousness trying to explain
Consciousness in terms of something else
that isn't Consciousness itself that I
think is is hopeless because we cannot
play the reductive game forever we
cannot keep on reducing one thing to
another forever unless we engage in
circular reasoning
um so at some point we hit sort of the
bottom level of reality
and we can then explain everything else
in terms of that ontological primitive
that we find at the end but we can't
explain the ontological Primitive itself
and that's inevitable whatever one's
theory of nature is you have to come
down to at least one ontology primitive
and I think Consciousness is it I think
we can make sense of everything else in
terms of Consciousness but we can also
we cannot reduce Consciousness awareness
phenomenality itself uh to something
else and the attempt to do that I think
is hopeless and leads to the signs of
internal contradictions that we refer to
as the heart problem of Consciousness
for instance
and again that calls back to Galileo
which I think Philip Goff who's a past
guest on the podcast as well spoke about
Galileo's error which was as far as I
understand it yeah this primitive notion
of of the the hard problem in the
context of you know can something inside
the medicine bottle ever really read
what's on the outside label uh and I do
feel like there is an incredible
um you know gap between what what we do
work on in uh actual you know sort of
proper scientific reasoning with
instruments and and so forth and
reproducibility it seems almost
impossible to think though that we could
ever reproduce or have a control group
with Consciousness and that I think
leads many people to think about uh
maybe philosophically entertaining But
ultimately you know impractical sorts of
experiments I mean are you aware of any
you know true experiments that could
shed a light uh no pun intended on
Consciousness as a other than you know
kind of metaphorically the dashboard the
the instrument panel of yours Etc are
the only gadonkan experiments or can we
actually do real law on this to goodness
experiments in the physical sciences
I I think we can I think a neuroscience
has been showing that experimentation
around awareness phenomenality
Consciousness itself is possible and
it's productive to a larger degree the
entire field of the Neuroscience of
Consciousness the notion of the neural
correlates of Consciousness is based on
measurement and subjective reports
individuals who report what they are
experiencing now are there problems with
that are there limitations surely there
are for instance when you are basing
your study on reportability you do not
distinguish between raw Consciousness or
phenomenal Consciousness as we said on
the one hand and on the other hand meta
Consciousness or or or conscious meta
cognition which goes on top of awareness
it's meta-conscious Consciousness is
what you have when in addition to
experiencing you know that you
experience now to report an experience
you have to be meta-conscious of it
otherwise you will say well I'm not
having that experience well in fact you
may be experiencing it so there is that
limitation the Neuroscience
neurosciences today try to get around
that with the so-called no report
paradigms but then you get Limited in
all kinds of other ways but I think it
is productive to to have some science
around fundamentality around
Consciousness what we will not succeed
and unfortunately that seems to be the
goal for most Sciences around
Consciousness is to reduce Consciousness
to physiological brain activity to to
neural metabolism the the very attempt
to do that presupposes a certain
metaphysical assumption which is that
what Consciousness is reducible and that
the correlation between brain activity
and Consciousness is a causal one
and that that I think is hopeless
um and to complement the Neuroscience of
Consciousness I think the way to go is
to um to have introspective
investigation which is not science we
should not add introspection to science
because it will break the bank of
science's horse and we will lose a very
very useful horse that we should keep
and protect and maintain healthy but in
addition to science I think it would be
very productive even for the scientists
who practice the science of
Consciousness to develop a little more
sophisticated
introspective awareness to know a little
bit more firsthand what it is that they
are actually studying because the level
of introspective naivete amongst
philosophers of mind and neuroscientists
of Consciousness is sometimes scary it's
it's it's
um
because why why why do you say that
well because you one is dedicating one's
life to studying Consciousness which can
only be actually known from
introspection a first person perspective
but one is extremely naive about what
that word means so how can one study it
from the outside if one doesn't actually
know what one is studying I mean there
are attempts made by famous and
neuroscientists who say that and I quote
Consciousness doesn't happen
Consciousness doesn't exist and when you
read their material what you realize is
that what they call Consciousness is a
kind of ethereal sense of individual
subjectivity a kind of individual eye
within a kind of Soul or spirit and and
that's what they explain away well very
good it's not like anybody was waiting
for for that kind of proof of the
obvious but they confuse that with what
philosophers call phenomenal
Consciousness which has nothing to do
with individual Identity or some kind of
individual so it's about experience
itself phenomenality it's a type of
existence that is defined in terms of
qualities as opposed to quantities you
cannot specify or fully describe
experiences on on the basis of physical
quantities what is the length in
centimeters of a thought what is the
weight in kilograms of an emotion what
is the color of of a memory I mean
that's where things go wrong when a
no otherwise famous neuroscientist makes
proclamations about the ability to
reduce Consciousness to nothing while in
fact what he is referring to as
Consciousness is not is not
Consciousness at all I think there is
that is unfortunate and a little more
introspective Insight would would
improve and help everybody to engage in
a more productive dialogue
so I I think it is uh it is useful to
kind of maybe for the audience to kind
of state some of your positions which
I'll summarize at least as I understand
them but please correct me if I'm wrong
in the likely scenario that I'm wrong
but as far as I understand it you are
not uh although you are materialistic in
some sense you don't believe that
computers will ever be able to approach
the uh conscious experience or even the
the thought process that humans can
engage in is is that correct am I
summarizing your your position or
I'm not a materialist uh okay not at all
I don't think that the foundational
level of nature is material or physical
or describable in terms of quantities at
all I don't think that is true
um I am very skeptical of the notion
that one can build a silicon computer
and expect it to have private conscious
in their life the way you and I have
because when you talk about conscious
computers what we mean is more than just
the fact that there is consciousness
associated with it what we mean is that
a computer would be conscious in the
same way as you and I are in other words
a computer would have private conscious
states that are accessible from the
inside but not from the outside that I
think is a very unproductive fantasy it
arises from some silly psychology
because nature is telling us that what
private conscious in our life looks like
when observed from the outside
is warm moist neurochemistry that's what
it looks like so why would a silicon
computer that no doesn't metabolize
doesn't burn ATP doesn't release
neurotransmitter molecules doesn't have
action potentials where we can imitate
action potential so that's not a good
example but doesn't have any of the rest
why would that be what private conscious
in their life looks like it's completely
arbitrary the mistake made here is to
mistake a simulation for the thing
simulated we don't make that mistake for
anything else I mean nobody would
mistake a
kidney function simulation on a computer
for a kidney producing urine nobody
would expect the computer to pee on
one's desk because one knows that a
kidney stimulation even if accurate down
to the molecular level is not the thing
simulated but when it comes to the
patterns of of mental activity in a
human being we think the simulation is
the thing simulated and that's
extraordinary extraordinarily naive no I
don't think anything computer will ever
have private conscious in their life
yeah I really resonate with what you're
saying a lot of the problems that I have
are things that are controversial like
predicting future climate change neglect
the fact that no simulation really is
capable of of capturing the complexity
in a complex system not just a
complicated system but a but a complex
system like the the weather on planet
Earth the only computer that can do that
it seems is the Earth itself and that's
not very useful if you have you have to
build a planet-sized computer to do a
simulation of that very planet but I I
do maybe push back on one thing that I
think that quantum computers are very
very good at simulating the properties
of quantum computers uh you know it's
it's almost recursive that they uh that
they can you know simulate lagrangians
and they can understand
um they can actually quite sufficiently
calculate uh future behaviors of you
know to within Realms of uncertainty but
but that might be the only case and that
may be the only not only the only
instance of a simulation that accurately
simulates something that it was intended
to simulate but that may be the only
good thing that they can do besides
maybe you know breaking Quantum codes of
you know some spies or something like
that but uh but yes I do agree and but
that's where you know to be honest it
feels hopeless you know I'm just a
simple experimentalist I built
telescopes we we analyze the telescope
data uh it's highly processed but you
know I've had conversations with many
many many philosophers including the
guests that I mentioned earlier
and it always comes down to this you
know recursion of of you know uh
infinite Turtles kind of all the way
down um whereas we kind of know
Consciousness when we see it and I guess
my my question you know to you is that
you know if we have a um uh this
evolutionary propensity to develop
Consciousness as you I believe but
always correct me if I'm wrong Vernon
because I may have gotten this wrong uh
you know in all the preparation I was
doing but I believe that you believe
that that Evolution you know has kind of
uh provided a mechanism by which the
experience of Consciousness that we
perceive has taken place and I know that
Donald Hoffman has this desktop
interface modality in which he has an
analogy for how we perceive it but um
but both of those are kind of driven by
evolute darwinian evolutionary uh uh
mandates but I wonder what isn't there
kind of a a disconnect because we don't
see animals you know conscious in
exactly the same way even though they've
been involved solving you know we've had
50 000 generations of certain E coli
strands they don't seem to exhibit
Consciousness as far as we can tell or
is that just a bias that I have as a
human being that my Consciousness is
better than an electrons you know pan
psychic Consciousness Am I Wrong
shouldn't we expect to see if evolution
really does Drive why is there only one
species of one primate of all the
different primates of all the millions
of species why is there only one that
exhibits plausible notion of what we
call consciousness
okay there's a lot to unpack here yeah
sorry so I'll I'll take various
departing points
um if you study a microscopic life
closely
I think you would be amazed how many
signs of private conscious in your life
a single cellular organisms manifest
you can watch amoeba single-celled
organisms
building little vases little houses out
of mud particles they pick from the
bottom of the puddle where they live and
then they they enter it and they live in
there you can watch paramecium go after
food and navigate what is essentially a
labyrinth going after food running away
from threats
it is baffling
If You observe carefully how many signs
of conscious in your life essentially
all life manifests and they all
metabolize like we do they all do
protein folding transcription ATP
Burning uh ATP burning not all of them
but um they share many of the
fundamental traits of life that we have
so I would I would
dispute the premise of your question
that only highly evolved animals like
maybe you know primates and pachyderms
and cetaceans exhibit signs of conscious
in their life
many animals for instance corvidians
they they express a sorrow they they do
little rituals around their fallen
comrades
um I I live with three cats I have had
animals all my life there's no doubt in
my mind whatsoever that they they have
conscious in their life now
I don't think Consciousness itself has
evolved I think Consciousness as an
ontological category as a type of
existent
is where it all begins from it's what is
there from the get-go so it didn't
evolve I think what evolved are
dissociated complexes of a field of raw
phenomenal Consciousness that spans the
entirety of Nature and what those
dissociated complexes look like is what
we call Biology is what we call life and
then the inner mental complexity of
these dissociated processes that evolved
as well and they and and these organisms
evolved over time higher level mental
functions that were not there in nature
in the beginning for instance what we
just talked about metacognition
self-awareness
these are things that have evolved
within life within dissociated complexes
of primary Consciousness so to say but
Consciousness as an ontological category
was there from the beginning and there I
am with Professor Donald Hoffman we we
both think that that Consciousness was
there from the beginning but the
contents of Consciousness or the
specific configuration of Consciousness
that has evolved over time because of
you know Fitness criteria entailed by
our ecosystem
how could you distinguish that type of
collective Behavior as you know
physicists Philip Anderson said more is
different he didn't say necessarily that
you know more is better more is worse he
said it's different in other words the
collective behavior of a pile of grains
of sand is very different than a hundred
million times one grain of sans behavior
when we have emergent phenomena that
comes up
um again I I mean to push back I mean
couldn't you say then that sand grains
are conscious I mean in the pan psychic
sense it seems to me that there could be
well when they get too heavy and they
have too much uh you know at risk to the
to the sand grain Colony I'm just making
this up please humor me uh then they
collapse and that's you know that's good
for the you know it's like a colony of
bees collapsing because sometimes you
need to have a new genetic strand that
kills off the bat anyway I'm making all
this up but but
um I mean who are we aren't we applying
a selective filter
um to the definition of Consciousness
that's not necessarily you know
intrinsic to it you know the famous the
map is not the territory I hate that
phrase because I have I have a I
actually have uh some territory that's a
map and I say the map is the territory
I'm just kidding uh but but you know
could you not say the Sim similar things
available much much weaker about grains
of sand
um you know even uh you know the
eukaryotic life forms and uh and perhaps
uh electrons themselves I mean this is
getting into pan psychism so maybe you
could say something about your thoughts
on pan psychism
um contrary to living organisms that do
manifest behaviors that are very
suggestive of their being correlated
with conscience in their life I don't
think grains of sand manifest any
behavior that would suggest that they
are conscious
um
you alluded to Anderson and more is
different
um I I don't think Anderson was
defending some kind of uh um how to say
strong emergence I think what he was
highlighting is that there may be
organizing fundamental organizing
principles in nature that kick in only
when Systems pass a certain threshold of
complexity because why would all the
laws of physics manifest only at the
microscopic level there may be
organizing principles that kick in at
higher levels and there there is some
suggestive evidence in science that
certain behaviors of nature cannot be
reduced to First principles at the
microscopic level so that's how we
interp I would interpret that but I
wouldn't interpret that at all as a
defense of Consciousness as some kind of
strongly emergent property because I
don't think that that's there at all
regarding pen psychism I am very
critical of it you see I think there are
many errors they make but one way to
frame the error is to confuse the
structure of what is perceived
for the structure of the perceiver
if you repeat it so it sinks in and
scientists confuse the structure of what
is perceived
with the structure of the perceiver
and and the thought goes like this
if I look at
an organism it's made of Parts it's made
of cells those cells are made of
molecules and I as the Observer I have a
body like that also made of cells
therefore my mind should be should be
made of Parts it should be constituted
of some kind of microscopic CEO of
consciousnesses that come together in my
brain well that is mistaking the
structure of what is perceived for the
structure of the perceiver I think there
are many reasons why panicism is
untenable one is logical you cannot have
a explicit and logical account for how
micro levels objectivities can combine
to form a higher level seemingly unitary
subjectivity such as my inner life of
your inner life
um another reason and you know you're a
physicist that that that will come
closer to home for you I think then
psychism is physically incoherent
because pen psychists take Elementary
subatomic particles to be little beads
uh and but we we have known since at
least finally in the 40s and Quantum
electrodynamics that's that's not what
elementary subatomic particles are they
can't be like that otherwise we cannot
account for Quantum fluctuations that
there are so many things we cannot
account even for the interactions of
particles because particle interactions
are not given to us by by quantum theory
they're given to us only by Quantum
field Theory another quantum field
Theory particles are ripples of quantum
fields which are themselves spatially
Unbound and span at the whole of nature
so pen psychism assumes that particles
are little beads while we have known
arguably since the 1920s I know some
physicists would say no no you're full
of [ __ ] that since the 1940s don't take
away this price from fine fine since the
1940s we have known that that's not what
particles are so yeah no it's it's a
hopeless it's a hopeless uh yeah I agree
and so those who say that the hard
problem is really a superposition of
many easier problems which maybe you
were hinting at at some level just that
the filtration effect uh what do you
make of those claims Dennett and others
have said that you know the hard problem
it's it's really just a bunch of you
know it's like the the strong anthropic
principle maybe that's just a bunch of
weak anthropic principles superimposed
what do you make of Dennis claim that
the hard problems it's really not it's a
misnomer
what then it tries to do is
fundamentally incoherent because he's
like he never closes his line of
argument he acknowledges that so let's
not blame him for that he's the first
one to say yes I haven't closed my line
of argument but
if we can if we pay attention to how
this this his argument unfolds what he
does is he's saying many of the contents
of consciousness
actually do not correspond to objective
states of Affairs in the world in other
words we we have Illusions we mistake
things for other things we think we are
experiencing certain things that exist
out there and it turns out our
experiences were illusory those things
were not out there now
if we extrapolate that line of argument
and we even grant that for the sake of
argument let's say that everything is an
illusion that is let's say that all of
our experiences do not correspond to
objective states of Affairs in the world
that our entire lives everything we take
to be true
is in fact an illusion that we are
fooling ourselves does that prove that
Consciousness is not there
or does that prove that Consciousness is
everything because Illusions are
experienced there is nothing to an
Illusion by definition other than the
experience of it because that experience
doesn't correspond to your objective
states of Affairs in the world so all
you have is the experience that's what
an illusion is it's a pure experience so
by arguing that all the contents of
Consciousness are illusory what we are
actually saying is that always in
Consciousness and only in Consciousness
we will never manage to pull out of this
argument like a magician pulling a
rabbit or a rabbit out of a hat that
there is no consciousness because
Consciousness is that within which all
those Illusions unfold so no that then
its attempt is fundamentally flawed and
has been so since at least 1991. now
another person that who hasn't conceded
uh any any ground at least to to my
knowledge to your criticisms of her work
is a past guest in front of the show
Sabina hasenfelder many of her Channel
audiences subscribes to this Channel and
are probably listening right now so you
wrote an article back in early earlier
this year called the fantasy behind
Sabina hasenfelder's super determinism
and then you had a debate uh with my
good friend Kurt J mungle as the as the
mediator moderator however you want to
call it I I personally think debates are
almost pointless but uh because very few
people come away changed from their
original perspective they get reified
and and more sunk cost into their
original philosophy but first would you
mind describing uh the the notion of
super determinism and and perhaps steel
Manning or in this case steel womaning
uh sabina's position and why she
believes what she believes what's
accurate about that and then um why you
guys have this continuing uh kind of uh
friendly but but dispute nonetheless so
first of all what is super determinism
in your mind what does it mean to you
what's wrong with it and then what's
right about sabina's uh interpretation
as a steel womaning uh attempt yeah
I was still a woman in it yes because a
lot of people do present super
determinism in a way that it is not what
Sabine is trying to get to put forward
some people confuse super determinism
for instance with an argument against
Free Will and that goes way further than
it needs to go for super determinism to
to make some sense the claim is the
following in experiments with entangled
particles we know statistically now in
the desires one the Nobel Prize in
physics this year after 40 Years of
experimental confirmation so we know
that the physical properties that we
measure on a particle the properties
that Define what the particle is the
properties that Define physicality such
as angular momentum which is a popular
one in this kind of experiments those
properties are are a function our
function of the experimental setup
in other words what you what you see
about a particle depends on what you
choose to measure about another particle
entangled with the first one
so the particles don't don't seem to
have a priori physical properties their
physical properties seem to arise from
from measurement and it seems to be that
the act of measurement it's what brings
physicality into existence which I think
is correct by the way now in an attempt
to try to save physicality to say no no
there were physical particles there
before
if you say that then you have to explain
why everything unfolds as if the act of
measurement determine the physical
properties and the way to go about it in
super determine super determinism is to
say that there are hidden variables in
the the particles and the detectors
that establish a causal chain in the act
of measurement whereby the setup of the
measurement apparatus causally changes
the particle
in a non-local way or even yeah it would
have to be a non-local way
now why do I think this is baloney why
do I think this is a fantasy for a
number of reasons
one of them is to try to bring the
assumptions that have to be made at the
microscopical level microscopic level
try to bring them into a level that we
can relate to with our intuition what
super determinism requires is equivalent
to the following
suppose you take your camera and you
want to photograph the moon at night and
then you set your aperture and you set
your exposure time in your camera and
you point the camera to the Moon and you
photograph it what super determinism
would say in this analogy is that what
the moon is
the physical properties of the Moon such
as its perimeter its mass whatever
are a function of the aperture and the
exposure time in your camera
so if you would set your camera
differently to a different aperture or a
different exposure time then the moon
would be different
that's what is required
um I think that is not intuitive it's a
it's a rather extraordinary hypothesis
but to make it worse
there isn't even the beginning of a
theoretical account of what the
necessary hidden variables might be
Sabine and nobody else is telling us
what the hidden variables are and that's
the core of physics I mean that's how
physics is done when Peter Hicks first
proposed the Higgs boson back in the 60s
he gave us a full well a fairly complete
characterization he told us I expect it
to be found in this energy range I
expect it to decay in this and these
particles because nobody has ever
measured the Heats directly to the case
before you before it interacts within
experi any measurement surface so you
have to know what it decays into in
order to reconstruct the event and be
able to say there was a Higgs in there
he also told us coherently how the Higgs
boson plays its role how it leads to
inertia in other words to to mass uh by
means of the Higgs field that sticky
field that prevents things from moving
at the speed of light all the time so we
had a complete map of what to look for
when we started looking for it back in
1994 and I know because I was there when
the the the atlas experiment was
proposed and approved we knew what we
were looking for we knew where to look
and how to look but there is no such a
thing for the hidden variables of Super
Duty determinism they are just a
placeholder and as such an expression of
Faith the faith is there has to be
something God knows what that does
God knows how what needs to be done for
us to be able to hold on to our
prejudice that physical entities have
Standalone existence and are not happy
phenomenal I don't think that's good
science and in that debate asabina told
to my face that she had she had
determined what the hidden variables are
that she had published a paper saying
what the hidden variables are and when I
looked at the paper it was a toy model
in other words those were the hidden
variables of a fantasy Universe not
hidden variables that are plausible or
tenable in any way in this universe so
no the hidden variables are just a a
placeholder for fantasies and Wishful
Thinking as of this time and to her
credit she did propose one experiment
that in principle doesn't need the
hidden variables to be determined in
advance it doesn't matter what they are
the experiment could produce a relevant
outcome either way the problem is and I
don't know how how much detail you want
to get here and that experiment is
non-falsifiable
in other words because we don't know
what the hidden variables are once the
experiment produces a negative result
you can always say well it's it just is
not accurate enough
we didn't repeat the measurement fast
enough uh to account for entropy or
anything else so it's not it's to never
be a conclusive experiment because it
cannot falsify the hypothesis that
motivated it to begin with so I don't
think that's productive either
when I have talked with others in the
past including Chalmers and uh Philip
Goff you know I've proposed this notion
of kind of the Drake equation for
determining Consciousness but of course
with the Drake equation it's not really
an equation it's just some kind of
parameterization perhaps but the the
biggest uh you know claim to fame that
it has is it's very well known it's very
frequently described and I think you
know there's sort of you know a
necessity for that to have uh to both
clearly understand that we
apply a filter no matter what we're
doing as as as measuring you know uh
devices or as as entities we are
applying our prejudices our biases Etc
that we have to be on guard against and
I think you know most people don't
really uh think about it in those
Notions that when we say the Drake
equation I mean we're not looking at
well there could be life you know in 19
Dimensions you know that doesn't appear
in the in the in the in the product of
of terms right so there's always a a you
know kind of hidden assumptions that go
into it maybe not hidden in the sense of
hidden variables necessarily but uh but
but I think it is important to realize
that we have these biases and I wonder
you know I always say with the Drake
equation it's it's sort of you know not
even again it's not even wrong it's not
even an equation but the most important
parts of it to whatever extent it's
useful would be the error analysis like
you as a scientist you and you and I we
know we don't just quote the average of
something some number of some we call it
the error bars and it's the error bars
that are much much harder to obtain than
the central value I mean the Higgs you
know at the mass that you mentioned the
125 tev that's not the interesting thing
it's the errors that go into the
measurement of that that are so
important so I I wonder if we're not
also kind of making a mistake when we
think about these these tasks so to
speak that you know we are applying our
prejudices and we have to be very much
on guard as Feynman said against fooling
ourselves I think one of the easiest
ways to fool ourselves is to ignore the
fact that we are participating in this
event itself so uh you don't necessarily
have to respond to that but but I'm
wondering you know is there a way that
that is there a framework that we could
address like a Drake Equation at least
it's convenient and it's popular or
whatever but is there a way that we
could you know perhaps learn to
parameterize our ignorance of what is
conscious or what is not conscious is
there some kind of framework that's you
know mechanized or uh that you could you
could recommend or is it is it really ad
hoc and we kind of have to make it up as
we go along
no I don't think you turned hog I think
if we pay attention to Nature Nature
gives us the hint I think if you look at
the behavior of the different entities
in nature it's pretty clear that the
ones that give us signs that we can
relate to as conscious entities that
those other entities are also conscious
consistently are entities that have what
we call metabolism
look the variety of life is is almost
unimaginable organisms can be so
comprehensively different that it's hard
to find any common thing across
different varieties of life but there is
one very clear common thing which is all
life metabolizes if you if you zoom in
with a microscope at a sufficiently
large degree of magnitude if we see that
all that seeming diversity
boils down to commonality
um you know even archaea have those
commonalities by the way we may be RTI
it turns out but that's another that's
another whole other other thing all life
has those characteristics which are not
trivial they are incredibly complex they
are very very very distinct none of it
can none of it can be considered casual
for instance protein folding
we don't know how to solve that
computationally to this day and your
body does it in like one or two seconds
um and ATP burning and transcription I
mean these are amazingly sophisticated
and non-trivial things that unify our
life so I would say if we pay attention
to that with an open mind pay attention
to Nature with an open mind what we have
a reasons to consider conscious entities
are living entities
rocks don't give us reason to think that
uh uh um
minerals in general some would say well
Stars if you look at you know the
patterns of the electromagnetic fields
in Stars they are similar to to to
organic brains maybe but then you then
you have to abstract away the fact that
the substrate is completely different
the fact that the physical regimen is
completely different what's happening in
Stars that's plasma regimen that's
complete easily different from the 37
degrees in which stuff is happening in
our brains you have to ignore size
you have to ignore so many things to
make that leap which I think look as you
know from science science is not about
what we can prove not to be the case
right because at the vast majority of
things cannot be unproven I cannot prove
that there isn't a Flying Spaghetti
Monster
I cannot prove that there isn't a teapot
in the orbit of Saturn right now because
maybe aliens came here in the 19th
century stole one and dumped it on their
way back home and they got caught by
Saturn that a great many silly things
cannot be unproven of course the
important question to ask is not what we
can disprove the important question to
ask is what do we have reasons to
seriously entertain as a hypothesis
and I submit to you that the only things
we have a reason to seriously seriously
entertain the hypothesis that they have
private conscious in their life of their
own are living things that metabolize
which excludes different viruses
yeah again excludes uh the pan psychic
approach right uh so I want to reset uh
just for people that are tuning in we've
got over a hundred and uh nine people
that are watching live and many many
hundreds more thousands more watch later
talking with Dr Bernardo Castro uh he's
in the Netherlands now the lower regions
of the lower regions and it's great to
have him on I've wanted to have on many
many times thanks to Kurt J mungle for
making the the shitok the introduction
between the two of us we've had on many
many great guests in the past talking
about different aspects of consciousness
of positivism materialism
um uh ranging from earlier conversation
that we mentioned David Chalmers and
Philip Goff uh to uh to more recently
the conversation that we had with Nick
Bostrom and uh and then even more
recently conversation we had with uh
with Stuart hammeroff and Sarah Roger
Penrose and I want to get your reaction
to both of those first let's let's turn
towards you know it's like you can't
have a conversation as a podcaster now
Bernardo without uh without talking
about Bitcoin or aliens
um or the simulation hypothesis so uh
what is the simulation hypothesis and
how do you react to it as a productive
or is it is it counterproductive to the
project that you're embarking on
it depends on what people mean by it
because
people mean so many different things
when they talk about the simulation
hypothesis I'll start with
one possible meaning that I think is
completely useless downright silly which
is the notion that our physical universe
and even our Consciousness as conscious
beings are the product of some
simulation run into in a physical
computer
um in some kind of meta Universe uh our
universe being the result of that
simulation in some other computer of
some other civilization why do I think
this is useless because it doesn't solve
any problem it just postpones the
problem it says well our metaphysical
problem is solved because now we can say
our world is just simulated it's
simulated in in that meta Universe yeah
but what is then the ontological nature
of that meta Universe you just postpone
the problem you just moved it away
without giving any solution whatsoever
and the price of moving it away is by
entertaining a hypothesis for which we
have precisely zero empirical evidence
none but whatsoever so that you just add
stuff that's a that's the clearest
violation of auckland's Razor of the
principle of parsimony that one could
think of
um except for the multi-universe the the
anyway I'll not get into that
um now is there a a charitable way to
interpret the simulation hypothesis in a
manner that makes it useful or
productive yes but uh if you understand
it you would probably not call it a
simulation hypothesis the interpretation
would be the following
the physical world we see around us
is not the world as it is in itself
it is just how the world as it is in
itself presents itself to us
physicality is not the thing in itself
physicality is a representation
probably our own cognitive
representation it's an appearance
Donald Hoffman would call it a virtual
reality headset
I would call it a dashboard of
instruments physicality is what appear
on our dashboard of instruments when we
make measurements on the world in order
to navigate our environment just like
the airplanes sensors make measurements
of the sky outside and the results of
those measurements are displayed on the
dashboard the dashboard conveys
important and accurate information about
what's going on in the world as it is in
itself in the sky outside so much so
that you can fly purely by instruments
you can you can land your playing safely
without even ever looking through the
window if even if the airplane didn't
have Windows the mistake we make is that
we take the dashboard for this guy
outside because the screen of perception
is our dashboard our sense organs are
sensors they make measurements on the
world those measurements are presented
to us in the form of the colors we see
the sounds we hear the sense we smell
textures we feel the flavors we taste
these are these are our Dash our
dashboard dials so to say uh and they
convey important and accurate
information about the world if you
ignore them you will walk under a truck
um so we should take the dashboard
seriously but not literally what we
think is that the dashboard is the world
that the physical world is the world as
it is in itself even though even though
that leads to all kinds of problems in
foundations of physics and philosophy we
insist on on that transposition
if you interpret the simulation
hypothesis to mean that the physical
world is just an appearance then I would
say yes that's productive but I wouldn't
call it a simulation because a
simulation seems to suggest that it is a
how to say a premeditated thing that
some intelligent organism set up just to
deceive us I don't think that's going on
that's what's going on at all I mean
early on you you thought there was a
materialist and I corrected you I'm not
a materialist what I am and that that's
probably what misled you I'm a
reductionist and I am a naturalist in
other words I think we we should explain
one thing in terms of another until we
are left with only one thing in our
reduction base in terms of which we can
explain everything else and I think
nature unfolds spontaneously in in the
naturalist sense I think nature does
what it does because it is what it is
not because it has some kind of skewed
devious plan to deceive us I don't think
that's what's going on I mean did nature
deceive Us by making it look like the
sun is in the orbit of the Earth
no we deceived ourselves it was our own
stupidity the sun is the sun it's doing
what it does you know it doesn't care
what we think of it and so I'm a
naturalist in that sense I think nature
does what it does because it is what it
is it's not nobody is trying to simulate
or deceive but the physical world is
just an appearance I think the world as
it is in itself is not describable
through numbers through physical
quantities
um and and I would argue that by
interpreting the physical world in this
way you would solve so many seemingly
insoluble problems in foundations of
physics today
very good uh so I think uh what we
should do now is turn to some of the
slides that you've provided I'm going to
run the slideshow uh from my computer
here okay good so I've got this queued
up and you should be able to see the
slides over there there we go and I will
let us go forth let's see if this will
work
so can you still see the screen uh do
you see it as full screen on on YouTube
or do you see yeah okay okay great so
Cynthia Foundation Veronica strip at
sensorfoundation.org okay you see it
says is physics about an external you
see that yeah okay great so take it away
okay this was a presentation in which I
tried to argue that physics would be
um
easier to do and more productive
especially foundations of physics if we
did not make metaphysical assumptions
and we stuck just to the data
um one metaphysical assumption that is
so common most people don't even know
that it's an assumption is the
assumption that the physical world is
the world outside
that the world outside is exhaustively
describable through physical quantities
uh and that's mistaking a representation
for the thing in itself potentially all
we have is perception perception is how
the world presents itself to us and
physics is a science of perception
physics asks the question and I I credit
uh Dr Marcus Miller uh for that uh it's
the question that physics physics asks
is what will I see next that's the whole
business of physics is to predict what
we will see next now when you go and say
those physical entities that I see and
that I can I can characterize through
numbers they are the entities of the
world out there as it is in itself
independent of my observation or my
measurement that's an enormous
metaphysical assumption and one that we
can actually in fact
dismiss or not dismiss but refute and
that's the contents of the next slide
so is the physical world out there as it
is in itself what it looks like to us
that's the question so if you go to the
next slide
one line of argument to say that it
cannot be uh uh is was defended by Carl
friston uh already a few years ago and
it's based on the notion of entropy now
you know he uses very complex
mathematics which is difficult to follow
he uses the notion of Markov blankets
but to summarize it in a way that
everybody can understand the argument is
the following there is no upper bound
upper limit to the entropy of the states
of the world out there we cannot put an
upper bound to that because it doesn't
depend on us it's nature so for all we
know there is no upper bound to the
dispersion of the states of the world
if we saw the world as it is in itself
that would mean that our inner cognitive
States mirror the states of the world
that's what it means to see the world as
it is our inner cognitive States mirror
the states of the world but then that
would mean that there would be no upper
bound to the dispersion of our inner
cognitive states there would be no upper
bound to our internal entropy and
therefore we cannot guarantee that we
could maintain our our structural and
dynamical integrity just merely by
looking at the World by looking at the
world for all you know you could melt
into hot soup but we have never seen
that happen we've never seen any living
being melt into hot soup by the mere
fact that it is observing the world so
no our inner cognitive States cannot
mirror the states of the world they are
encoded inferential representations
thereof which then put do put an upper
bound to our internal entropy that's one
argument and the next argument is
evolutionary we didn't evolve to see the
world as it is we evolved to see the
world in whatever way helps us survive
to give you an example that Don Hoffman
likes to use when you look at the
computer file on your computer on your
desktop you don't see the file as it
actually is the file as it actually is
are millions of open or closed
microscopic electronic switches right
now if you saw the files it actually is
that would be completely dysfunctional
you might as well throw the computer
away so you see a representation thereof
in the form of a little colored
rectangle on your computer desktop that
gives you accurate and actionable
information about the file but it
doesn't tell you how it doesn't present
the file to you as it actually is and
the same would apply for perception
nature would never evolve a cognitive
apparatus that shows us the world as it
is it would give us a dashboard of dials
just like the dashboard of dials of an
airplane that sort of summarizes and
conveys gives us a summary of
what is Salient about the world in a way
that does limit entropy like the scales
of the diodes are bound on both sides
and the variety of states of the
dashboard is so bound that you can write
an airplane manual telling you what to
do for all kinds of combinations of Dio
indications that's the physical world
it's our dashboard we don't have a
transparent windshield to see the world
as it is that would be deadly and
evolutionarily that would drive us to
Extinction swiftly as game theory has
shown and even our instruments don't
overcome this dashboard Paradigm because
we still need to perceive the output of
our instruments everything gets filtered
through the dashboard so if you go to
the next one
uh in physics there there is this series
of experiments I don't need to get into
details because it has won the no price
this year so by now everybody knows what
this is uh these experiments show us
that physical properties are a result of
measurement we cannot speak of physical
entities prior to a measurement or an
observation and the experiments go
roughly as follows they can be a lot
more complicated than this like Quantum
Quantum eraser experiments but in a
nutshell you produce two particles
together so they are entangled like two
photons and you shoot one Photon to the
left and one Photon to the right on the
left scientist Alice makes a measurement
of photon a after it has covered a
certain distance and on the right
scientist Bob makes a measurement on
photon B after it has covered a certain
difference distance and as it turns out
what Bob sees depends on what Alice
chose to measure in other words the
particles are not what they are prior to
measurement they acquire their physical
properties they become physical only in
the moment they are measured which takes
some people for a spin they think well
if the particles are not physical if
there is no physicality what is it that
we measure and then you go down the
Avenue that like Carlo Carlo or a valley
does the Avenue of infinite regress you
know it's Turtles all the way down
raveli says it's relations all the way
down uh if you go back to the previous
slide just for me to cover that very
quickly it's much easier to understand
this if we realize that physicality is
not the world as it is in itself
physicality is the results of
measurements just like what the dios
show on the dashboard of an airplane is
the result of a measurement if the
airplane sensors don't make any
measurements the dios show nothing
there's nothing on the dashboard does
that mean that there is no world of
course not the world that is measured
doesn't care whether you measure it or
not it's still there but physicality is
the dashboard so if you don't measure
yes then the dashboard shows nothing
without measurement there is no physical
world the world as it is in itself is
not describable through physical
quantities that's all the experiment is
telling and it lines up with the
argument of call Kristin the argument of
Donald Hoffman and we can go further in
the next slide we can understand why
there is such a tight correlation
between Alice's choice and Bob's
measurement even though Alice and Bob
cannot communicate and this is
experiment has excluded that possibility
the choice of measurement is made after
the particles are in flight so in the
previous slide still uh Brian very
quickly yeah how can you understand that
well imagine that you're watching a
soccer game at home on two television
screens because you are such a big
soccer fan and you're watching them in
two different brought with through two
different broadcasters and each
broadcasters has their own cameras on
the stadium
so the images will be different on the
two televisions but they will be
entirely correlated now if a 19th
century traveler were sitting next to
you the traveler would be amazed how do
the little man running Inside the Box on
the left know how to coordinate their
movements with the little man running
side the box to the right why does your
19th century guy become confused because
he thinks the images are the thing in
itself he thinks the football match is
the image on the TV that the little men
are inside the TV now we know that the
TV shows images representations the real
thing is the football stadium it's far
away
and the images are correlated because
they are both different representations
of the same underlying reality and the
way we should regard this this this
quantum entanglement experiments is
exactly like that physicality is an
image just like the television screen
that's why what Bob sees correlates
tightly with what Alice sees even though
they cannot communicate at all and there
is no causal link between the two
because physicality is an image
physicality is not the soccer match it's
the television image and the problem
disappears but we are 21st century
people seeing 21st century evidence with
thinking like 19th century people that's
that's where it goes wrong
so the next one so to to summarize this
and I think we are close to to the point
where you you want to stop it just to
bring in some technical Concepts uh our
inner cognitive States that's a set of
states that represented by the by the
letter r
uh and the world outside is an another
set of States independent of our inner
states let's represent it uh by the
letter PSI
so we interact with the world our inner
states interact with the states of the
world through some sensory States what
we perceive and some action States how
we act in the world merely by existing
and displacing a volume of air those are
the a States and the sensory states are
the S States and there are these causal
links across all of them and
mathematically you can model the sensory
and active States as a Markov blanket
and there's a whole set of mathematical
tooling that you get when you model
things this way and I think the way we
can model what's going on is to
understand that the set of States PSI
that constitute the world out there the
objective World objective nature as it
is in itself those states are not
physical States
physical states are the A's and S's
physical the physical world is a Markov
blanket that surrounds different living
beings that's why physics is relational
and there Carlo ravelli is Right physics
is relational because each one of us has
its own physical world as this sort of
layered set of Markov blentian states
that allows us to interact with the real
world now we all share the real world
there is only one real world that we
inhabit and those are the states side
but they are not physical
physical states are relational that's
what I try to show in this slide and if
you if you regard the problems in
foundations of physics today through
these lenses many of the seemingly
impossible
contradictions and and
um simulink soluble problems they
suddenly become treatable I don't claim
that they are solved through this no no
no problem is is not so trivially
solvable but at least they become
treatable there is a way to think about
them that is coherent very good
um so shall we take some questions now
Bernardo
sure let's do it okay great thank you
very much for that let me go back to
hearing good
um so we have uh over 100 people as I
said watching uh so far there's been
close to 500 people that have come in
and out of the chat room uh so let's
start going here the first one has to do
with and by the way you can always ask
questions I said on Twitter Dr Brian
Keating or on the YouTube channel itself
I solicit those before my guests come on
first one comes from Casper uh oblige uh
who asked what does Bernardo think about
quantum gravity theories maybe I can
just slightly tweak that and say what do
you think of um orc or the theory that
somehow the wild curvature tensor and
gravitational forces cause Consciousness
to occur
so these are two completely different
questions you know that so first orc or
um I think it's false
um and my criticism of it is it's not
original but uh but I think it's valid
which is that Consciousness seems
mysterious collapse seems mysterious oh
they might have something to do with one
another well I don't think nature works
like this I don't think that's how we
should go about Theory I have great
respect for sir Roger
um I think the Nobel Prize in physics
last year was more than deserved he
should have earned it before but he
didn't earn it for orc ore he earned it
for something else of course I think I
don't think Consciousness causes
collapse I don't think Consciousness has
this this magical power of changing the
states of the world as it is in itself I
think the very question disappears if
you regard foundations of physics
through the lens I just explained in the
slides we just went through and then the
whole issue about collapse is that that
whole thing disappears and we will adopt
a kind of
almost a Cubist approach to things uh
the the the the wave function is not the
world as it is it's our knowledge of the
world it's our best betting strategy and
you see that's how I would regard it now
Loop quantum gravity that's something
completely else there I am more
optimistic uh you know before it all we
had was uh M Theory and M Theory to say
that it's over determining is is is the
it's a I would say it doesn't even
approach the seriousness of the issue
um
and loop quantum gravity gives us at
least a handle on what I think will very
soon be the greatest mystery of the 21st
century Consciousness is not it I think
we have the solutions there it's a
matter of people getting used to it it's
a matter of the prejudices slowly
melting Under the Sun of Reason like
butter it takes a while it's not
instantaneous but it's going to happen I
think the greatest mystery of the 21st
century is time
because
time is discombobulating it's obviously
there and it's obviously not there
and loop quantum gravity may give us a
handle on at least the beginning of a
handle beginning of a mathematized way
of regarding it and so there I am more
I'm more optimistic about the quantum
gravity yeah okay a couple more
questions here
um Craig Sadler is asking what does Dr
castroups have to say about the
hypothesis or hypotheses like predictive
coding and active inference which mean
that perception is primarily a brain
generated construct appearing in
awareness well that's not what those
hypotheses say because the brain is an
object of perception
so for you to be coherent you have to
regard the brain as an actively
inferential modality of perception in
other words the brain cannot be taken as
it cannot be taken uncritically as a
thing in itself the brain too as a
content of perception is differentially
constructed it's a coded representation
of our of our cognitive system
um
that hypothesis does not reduce the
materialism it does not say that the
contents of perception as experiences
the quality of perception are reducible
to the brain all that it says is that
all the quality of perception including
the brains we see including the EEG
curves we measure all of that is a is an
encoded
inferential cognitive representation
produced by our cognitive system the
brain itself is one of those inferences
so if you to be internally consistent
with one hypothe one's hypothesis you
have to apply coded inferential
cognition to that very object we call
brain and brain activity otherwise you
know it's incoherent
foreign
good okay so uh let's see the next
question uh let's see I mean fast
forward a bunch there's so many good
questions here
um is consciousness uh fractal is there
a fractal relationship or maybe this has
to do more with the brain I don't know
you can interpret that any way you like
um
I think the contents of Consciousness uh
May largely be fractal
um
let me be more generic here I don't know
whether the whole of nature is fractal
large segments of it are and fractals
have
a rather uncanny applicability even in
game development by using fractals you
can construct very convincing artificial
Landscapes which sort of raises the
question might nature not be doing the
same thing I don't know whether nature
is fractal but I would say the following
more generically
um I'm a naturalist and a reductionist
so let me put the cards of my prejudices
on the table up front in an attempt to
be as honest as possible
I think that the key challenge
is the following
we can write the fundamental equations
of physics which is the queen of
Sciences we can write all the
fundamental equations of physics on half
a page in other words
and although there may be more
sophisticated organizing principles that
kick in at macroscopic levels and
therefore cannot be isolated under
laboratory conditions you cannot isolate
control the the variables in a
laboratory condition so we may be blind
to them they may exist to may be blind
to them so maybe it's a full page not
half a page but
there aren't many of these organizing
principles
um and then
that that's on the one hand on the other
hand the universe is exquisitely complex
and VAR and varied I mean the the the
the variety of phenomena
between the micro microscopic and the
macroscopic in nature it's just
mind-boggling
so how do you reconcile these two things
How can there be so few so simple
organizing principles that lead to this
massive complexity and I think what this
seems to indicate is that whether
fractal or not
nature Works through
an iterative application of self-similar
rules
fractals are an instance of that yes but
cellular automata another instance of
that and you can create a cellular
automatic automaton based on one or two
very simple rules and it produces
magnificent complexity magnificent
variety so because of these two
observations now the obvious complexity
of Nature and the obvious Simplicity of
Nature's organizing principles I think
we will have to come to some kind of
iterative self-similar application of
principles so an iterative rule that
applies itself to its own results again
and again and again and again to produce
the complexity of Nature and a fractal
is just one possibility in that
direction very good okay I'll take a
couple more questions here before it's
getting super late over there and I have
a meeting to get to in a few minutes too
so uh let's uh this question comes from
uh Anton sh what problem is philosophy
of Consciousness trying trying to tackle
is it related to some prediction of the
future as with science as with as it is
with science or something else which we
can't possibly fully verbalize so I
guess what is the what is the you know
really Zeitgeist of this field
well the the key motivation the feud
begun under the materialist Zeitgeist
under the materialist ethos which is
that uh
our mental life somehow should be
reducible to material brain activity and
material entities have Standalone
existence they are not the outcome of
measurement they are not that phenomenal
they are the thing in itself and and our
thoughts our conscious activities
somehow arises from that but there has
never been a an explicit and sufficient
account for that not even vaguely
sufficient so philosophy of Mind comes
in and tries to ask the question okay
what is consciousness then how does it
come to be what role does it play is
consciousness merely a witness or is it
part of the causal Nexus these are all
the open questions and they arise
fundamentally they are motivated
fundamentally by this assumption that
physicality precedes phenomenality in
nature ontologically that the phenomenon
arises from the physical which leads to
all these questions so that's the
motivation for the discipline once it
becomes commonplace and accepted that
Consciousness as a non-take category is
fundamental it's what there is
everything else arises from it then you
you could argue that the very field of
philosophy of mind will end uh because
it's asking questions for which we have
answers now we didn't explain
Consciousness but we explained
everything else in terms of
Consciousness which is just as good or
even better and then the field will
disappear and all there would be is the
Neuroscience of the contents of
Consciousness that will always be
relevant very good okay last question
I'll take uh before we wrap up and let
Bernardo uh get some some Slumber and
before he gets mad at me and says uh the
insult that I've received from many many
uh Dutchmen which is that I appear to be
Club phelomolin
Clough in the morning does that make
sense oh yeah okay okay head in the head
with a windmill uh okay so uh Kish
kashka
what is your take on Tom Campbell's
theory that the universe is more virtual
reality
depends on what he means by virtual
reality I had a conversation with him
some time ago and we agreed on a great
number of things so I think what he
calls a virtual reality is what they
call the dashboard and so he might
actually be in agreement in my area
that's great oh Bernardo uh it's been
such a treat I want to again thank my
good friend uh Kurt J mungle who is uh
the responsible for connecting us on his
channel is a model for mine has helped
me out so much I want to thank all the
viewers hundreds have watched it so far
well uh rebroadcast it we'll post it
repost it with some light editing in
just a bit and uh as a reminder you can
always follow uh Bernardo and myself on
Twitter uh Brian the two bks that should
be prominent in your mind uh the
Bernardo castrupa Twitter and I'm Dr
Brian Keating on Twitter and don't
forget to leave a comment on the video
thumbs up if you liked it if you want to
have more conversations maybe we'll do
part two if you'd like to see maybe just
a free-for-all with Don Hoffman I'm a
serious about this burn I'd like to have
you Don Hoffman Sabina and uh and also
Philip Goff on but do you do you think
that'll be productive or do you think
we'd kind of just devolve into a
shouting we would just agree
all right so boring you're redundant
yeah that's right okay well we'll figure
it out anyway I want to thank everybody
um do subscribe uh to my uh to my
mailing list if you want to receive a
piece of real honest to good space
Schmutz and this is actually a peanut I
think but uh but I do have some
unconscious or maybe pan psychic
meteorite material so that's at Brian
keating.com slash list you can find it
there we have great interviews coming up
on Tuesday uh we are featuring none
other than Francis halsen who is the
bright professor of he's a Belgian
physicist by training and he runs the
Ice Cube experiment and we had a
wonderful conversation about the uh
impact of new Ice Cube measurements
Bernardo I don't know if you heard this
on quantum gravity and constraining
Quantum grab with neutrinos which is
quite fascinating and I know you'll
enjoy that and others that will as well
and I just want to thank Bernardo so
much for coming on the show and uh again
leave a leave a comment if you want to
see that a mashup with a bunch of
scientists talking about Consciousness
uh in a debate form maybe we can make
that happen for now I want to thank you
all and I want to bid you a good night
and a good weekend over there uh
Bernardo get get some schluff uh it is
late there but I really appreciate this
it's been a lot of fun
thanks for having me Brian and giant I
enjoyed it a lot me too good night take
care
[Music]
[Music]